je suis tom holland et je suis mark wahlberg
et nous sommes sur le plateau en train de filmer
uncharted ouais comme si j'étais littéralement à seulement 30
pieds dans les airs escaladant un énorme navire
eh bien ce n'était pas tout à fait 30 pieds ouais c'était en
fait 40 pieds je  essayait juste d'être
modeste wow hé marque savez-vous ce que le
mot mèmes inexplorés cela signifie quelque chose de
tout nouveau jamais vu auparavant n'a pas encore
été mis sur une carte et c'est ce que
ce film est l'histoire inexplorée l'
action inexplorée les lieux sont
inexploré les personnages donc les
personnages sont peut-être un peu
cartographiés parce qu'ils sont basés sur une
franchise de jeux vidéo incroyablement populaire,
donc juste un peu de charité ouais je
joue nathan drake
il est ingénieux plein d'esprit super avec une
énigme vit pour l'aventure et il est le
plus grand trésor  chasseur de tous les temps
je joue le mentor plus sage et
beaucoup plus beau de sully nathan bien plus vieux ouais
mais vraiment ce sont les deux qui travaillent
ensemble ils travaillent juste
pourriez-vous déplacer une mauvaise cheville plus lente dans
un nat inexploré  e et sully vont dans les
endroits les plus incroyables du monde, vous
devriez voir certains des endroits où nous
voyageons c'est une énorme aventure de globe-trotter
nous sommes à la recherche d'anciens
trésors dépêchez-vous idiot nous allons nous noyer
cela va prendre un peu plus de temps que je ne le
pensais gamin qui  mène à des
cascades assez folles quand tu me frappes au
visage aujourd'hui avec cette épée pas de
prochaine fois ne te mets pas en travers de mon
épée prépare-toi pour l'aventure d'une
vie avec uncharted
[Music]
il y a des endroits dehors  là tu ne
trouves sur aucune carte
ils ne sont pas partis
ils sont juste perdus
hé gamin un peu jeune pour un barman
n'es tu pas un peu vieux pour le bal tu n'es pas
tout ici pourquoi la carte ce chemin
ferdinand magellan  pris la voile autour
du monde tu connais ton histoire
c'est le plus grand trésor qui n'a jamais
été trouvé cinq milliards facile
[Musique]
je pense que tu es ici parce que tu es ton
frère eh bien tu sais mon frère a dit
mais maintenant je sens la
Norvège  chèvre nous le trouvons aussi
w  ho diable est-ce que je suis un ami de
sully sally n'a pas d'amis je
devrais savoir que je suis l'un d'eux
cette
personne depuis très longtemps tellement de
sang
je suis à peu près sûr qu'il menace juste de
me tuer ne touche pas ton oreille comme ça
tu ressembles à un idiot tu n'as aucune idée avec
qui tu t'es associé
j'ai rêvé de ce truc
depuis que je suis enfant, mon frère
dit qu'un dernier
indice
[Musique]
oh mon dieu je ne devrais jamais sortir pour
croire avec nos grands garçons nous au cas où
vous êtes sur le point d'obtenir un bon accueil écossais
quoi
oh merde
vous